I'm going to tell you the truth that
people who are wealthy know that a lot
of poor people don't it takes the same
amount of effort sometimes more to close
a hundred dollar sale as it takes to
close a ten thousand dollar sale and
it's not because of the product you sell
but because of the prospect you're
speaking with picking the right customer
to sell to is one of the highest
leveraged things that you can do to make
more money because people have this
false belief that it must be harder to
sell those people or must be harder to
deliver those people and we've all seen
that Meme that says hey so what exactly
am I going to be getting for my fifty
dollars versus the wealthy client that
says hey wire sent yesterday for 50
Grand what do you want to do next the
faster you can learn that the faster you
can get to doing the same work with just
way more zeros